my kids know that i don't know every
single thing like they know i'm reading
from you know a book or looking
something up i'm like i don't know let's
look that up let's research that
together and i think that's beautiful
and healthy because then they're seeing
an example of a lifelong learner because
that's what i want them to be i want
them to not think that they have to go
around with all the answers i want them
to sit and say tell me more about that
or i love to research that more
and so
for them to see that in us i think is
awesome i don't think they need to need
a parent who knows everything i had to
kind of change my mind a little bit
about homeschooling and once i was in it
i really saw the benefits and
love that quote i love that book because
it's so important i think to really go
off the child's interest because that's
how they're going to remember things i
don't really remember anything yes from
school some things because i loved
anatomy and the body
so if we can focus on things that they
really enjoy they're going to love
learning and i think promoting a
lifelong learner is so important
[Music]
that was jenna and josefa two
homeschooling moms in our community that
i find so much inspiration from and they
are a wealth of knowledge when it comes
to this topic and how to keep the magic
alive when it comes to learning and
raising our children to be empowered
human beings to go out into the world
and just loving life and loving learning
in this episode we talk about all
different kinds of things ranging from
different homeschooling philosophies
their own homeschooling journey as well
as answering all different kinds of
common questions and concerns when it
comes to homeschooling like can you
homeschool if you have some financial
restrictions or different ways to handle
when kids aren't inspired to learn and
how to keep that magic live and children
loving learning we also talk a lot about
the different resources that inspire us
and i've put the links below for you
guys to check out so without further ado
let's get into this episode i really
hope that you enjoy this conversation
just talking about all different things
when it comes to homeschooling and
helping our children foster and grow to
be empowered beings as they grow all
right we're here thank you so much guys
for coming on the show today i feel so
thankful for anyone who's listening and
watching that my friends are coming on
my podcast especially within the topics
that i'm so inspired by them about and
so many
moms in our homeschooling community are
just mother community here where we live
are so inspired by these two wonderful
ladies josefa and jenna because you guys
are just so creative you're always just
keeping it really
just about the kids and about how
they're going thrive and you guys are
just so good at homeschooling it's
really inspiring so i'm really excited
for this conversation because i know a
lot of people are switching to
homeschooling homeschooling is really on
the rise right now and are just looking
for
ways to start and looking for some
answers on how to go about it so i think
this is going to be a great conversation
yes so excited about love talking about
homeschooling any chance we get so yeah
for sure me too i love it and i'm
excited to be here thanks for having me
well so the first question i want to ask
you is have you guys always homeschooled
and can you share a little bit about
your homeschooling journey
so
i guess i'll go first um i
never thought i would homeschool
actually
um i actually had a few friends who
homeschooled and i was like i don't
think i want to do that oh i thought it
was a little weird um it wasn't until
we sold all of our things and then moved
into an airstream travel trailer started
traveling around and we weren't close to
the kid's school anymore that we decided
hey why don't we try it out and see if
we like it because actually our kids had
to go to school a little earlier than i
wanted to i put them into a little
private school
that i loved their philosophy they did a
lot of nature things and gardening and
all that so they were in there for a
couple years at a private school and
then actually nico also went to a public
school so i kind of got to try out both
and see what it was like
but i have loved homeschooling and i'm
so happy to be doing it i'm going on my
fifth year now and i'm like i can't
believe i'm doing this so yeah that's
our journey
yeah awesome we i think i always knew i
wanted to homeschool um from the
beginning that's just that's been the
plan
so we've always done homeschooling from
the very start and i think we're in our
sixth year for counting from
kindergarten that's awesome i i as well
kind of just always knew i wanted to
homeschool i think
um but i love joseph too that you've had
different experiences with different
types of schooling as well so currently
where you guys are today what are your
homeschool philosophies per se
sure um
we have kind of shifted as time has gone
on which is really cool and it's part of
what i love about homeschooling is that
flexibility and freedom to just be like
oh this is kind of where our family's
going or the kids are going or what
they're needing
we've kind of moved into a more like i
call it kind of structured unschooling
or child led learning
we did curriculum for about three years
we did like a waldorf-based curriculum
which was wonderful and i feel like that
just kind of gave me that foundation i
needed and the confidence i needed to be
like oh i can do this i know what they
need to learn next and i know their
style and my learning teaching style
their learning style and um yeah now we
just kind of go wherever they lead and i
have a little bit of structure or plan
in my head but it's really just a little
more free-flowing now which is really
fun
yeah i would say we're similar in that
we i do take more of a child led
approach when i first started
homeschooling
i bought this guide kind of thing it's
from jody maccabee i love her if you
don't know her she's amazing she'll
check out her stuff
she has kind of like a home getting
started with homeschooling guide so i
bought it and i was able to kind of take
a look at it at it and then i started
researching philosophies and there was
there are so many different ones which i
know we'll talk about later but um i
became inspired by so many different
ones i'm like i can't pick one so i
would say i'm more of like an eclectic
homeschooler kind of take a little bit
of each thing
like um art and nature and interest-led
learning and kind of
mold it for exactly what my kids need
and it's always changing too
i used to never really do a curriculum
until i actually found one i liked and
we kind of use it more as like a
resourcing guide rather than you have to
do this every single day type of thing
we have all the resources there and then
i allowed them like what do you want to
learn about today and then we kind of
you know they get to pick and choose so
that's what i love to do i love
um
going out in nature a lot the boys surf
we go hiking we go on the ocean um and
yeah we just have a lot of fun together
that's awesome okay something that i
just thought of that i really think is
important to like preface in the
beginning and set the tone for this
conversation is why do you guys
homeschool well i would say
um some of the benefits to me have been
really um well why do i own school i
know like if someone's like why did you
choose homeschooling well it kind of
chose me actually because i was kind of
forced to do it
like i said we were in the travel
trailer and we were so far from the kids
school and i'm like i'm not gonna try to
find another school for them to go to
why not just try it out
and so i did and then i just loved it so
much so what have i loved from it i
guess the quality time that i get to
spend with my children that has been so
special to me being able to see what
they're really interested in and
passionate about and i really admit when
they were at school i really miss them
being gone i remember i would be driving
them to school and i'm like bye and i
just really missed that family time that
we got to have so being able to have
more family time has been
one of the things that has kept me
homeschooling and just that i get to
pick and choose things that they're
interested in to learn about
that has also kept me homeschooling so
yeah absolutely we love the freedom we
love that like with my husband's
schedule that he works a lot of evenings
and weekends that he actually gets to
spend time with them and we can do
school around his work schedule and we
just love
getting to follow their interests or
wherever they're at
in a subject if it's taking them a
little longer if they're just like
wanting to spend more time on it or
whatever it is we can
just cater our day and what they're
learning to them right
instead of like well this is what the
curriculum says i'm sorry you didn't
catch on in time we're moving on you
know right um so we just love the
freedom we love the freedom to be able
to travel
my husband's work sometimes gives us
opportunities to go places so if it's
like hey we are want to spend a month in
europe like let's go we can go do that
and
um yeah we just love all the freedom it
gives our family yeah for me it was
about like the interest-led learning
aspect
and taking i guess from my own
experience in school and not loving the
rigidness about it and not loving the
forced compliance like this is what you
have to learn there's really no other
options even if you were excited about
something else and then when i read the
book how children learn by john holt
that like really was a paradigm shift
for me and it really was like it just
made so much sense to me especially
taking from my own experience and
realizing that
i didn't absorb information well when i
wasn't excited about it
and so much of school was like that for
me that wasn't the experience of my
sister
my sister loved school she excelled in
school she loved the subjects for me i
just like was just didn't love it and so
when i'm going through the motions in
school and like all the testing and the
studying and the i think all the
the pressure to like feel like you're
good enough if you did well in school
like like whether you did well on tests
or not and just the
learning that like every kid learns
differently and how can we best support
children to learn the way that they're
gonna thrive best and so when i read
that book that was just like
mind-blowing to me because it made so
much sense one of the things he said was
about
about how children don't observe um
absorb the information if they're not
excited about that like that was just
yes like i completely had that
experience in school that if i wasn't
excited about it i did not absorb it and
then as i got into adulthood and figured
out what i actually was excited to learn
about i absorbed it so well
so i thought wow we should be doing this
for children from the beginning
and that was actually for me like the
main reason and i think a lot of that's
something that's important to note is
that
for a lot of homeschoolers it really
isn't about creating school at home it's
that it's not really
schooling at all and there's a quote
from john holt from that same author
that i really like
he says what is the what is most
important and valuable about the home as
a base for children's growth into the
world is not that it is a better school
than schools but that it isn't a school
at all
you guys have any thoughts on that i
love that i feel like that's
i
have completely changed the way i
thought i would do homeschooling i
thought it would just be like i'm
replicating school in my home and i
thought we're gonna have like all the
little supplies and my curriculum and
we're gonna do it for seven hours a day
and
you know i'm gonna wear my pencil skirt
you know i just thought like it was
gonna look like school but at home and i
just wanted to spend time with them and
i didn't totally even know all the the
whys behind i just knew that's what we
wanted to do
um but kids are the best teachers
and
the way they've taught me about how they
want to learn and how they learn best
and what their learning styles are
is what's shaped that for me and i'm
like oh you don't want to
sit at a desk for seven hours that's not
interesting to you and that
you know you said you hated school i
actually loved school and so to
homeschool for me was like no yeah like
i want my kids to be social and
be part of the the clubs because i was
part of like every club you can think of
like sign language club uh surf club
like polynesian islanders club like
every club
and sports i loved playing sports so i
thought you know man my kids are going
to miss out on these things prom
homecoming but then i realized no
actually they can get an enriched
homeschool life here
with me at home and there's so many
other homeschoolers now that we can do
things together we can have our own
graduation we can have our own little
party for like a homecoming if we wanted
to and so um yeah i had to kind of
change my mind a little bit about
homeschooling and once i was in it i
really saw the benefits and
love that quote i love that book because
it's so important i think to really um
go off the child's interest because
that's how they're going to remember
things i don't really remember anything
yes from school some things because i
loved anatomy and the body
so if we can focus on things that they
really enjoy they're going to love
learning and i think promoting a
lifelong learner is so important
and that's one of my goals yeah it
reminds me of that ted talk called hack
schooling makes me happy by logan
laplante have you seen that one it's
really good it's this unschooler kid
that did like a ted talk explaining his
schooling experience and how because
he's had like an unschooling
interest-led learning he's been able to
get into like an internship at a young
age which is for him it was about like a
snowboarding gear and so he got this
awesome internship at like i don't know
he must have been 14. he was pretty
young and seeing how he could really
follow his dreams at that moment and
maybe that's not going to be his dream
later but all the life skills he's
learning by being inserted into the real
world
at a young age what is really impactful
i think and i think a lot of times
people think that homeschooled kids are
ant are not social right or like you're
hiding them from society but i actually
beg to differ i think that
homeschooled kids as long as you're not
just like in the cabin in the woods
isolated right which could happen and
that's not that's not ideal that's not
something i don't think either of us are
advocating for where you're just like
isolated from society but most
homeschool kids at least the ones in our
community the ones that we know it
really is what you make of it and
you can insert them into the real world
because they're doing life throughout
the days with you they're not at school
all day sitting at a desk that really
isn't like real life anywhere else in
real life
and so i think that that's really
important important for people to
to realize that for one they can still
be part of sports and they can still do
all these like they can actually have
more freedom to follow their dreams and
the things that they're excited about
because they had the freedom of time
yes yeah and one of my favorite things
about homeschooling is that i can send
my kid to like a baseball or soccer
practice and not feel like man i haven't
seen them all day
i man like that's that would be hard for
me to send them to school from like
eight to two or whatever time it is and
then right after be home for maybe an
hour and then have to send them to
practice and then only get like an hour
at dinner time with them that to me i'm
like i want to spend more time with them
not that parents who
send their kids to school don't want to
spend time with them i think that
they do
um but it's just a different way of life
i guess for me i really
appreciate that i can just see them a
lot more
totally
there's also i think another thing uh a
really important
ted talk is i think it's a ted talk but
it's also on youtube as like the sketch
drawing that talks about how
homeschooling isn't like school at all
by sir ken robinson have you seen that
one it's called changing education
paradigms
and he kind of talks about like where
this how the schooling system
was started and why it became the way it
was at the time living in a completely
different timeframe meant for something
completely different than what we are
today as a society and our economy and
everything like that so i recommend
everybody go check out that it's called
changing education paradigms on youtube
by sir ken robinson it's really
mind-blowing but the next thing i want
to talk about is how is
is asking you guys if you see any
problems with modern or public schooling
but also actually before you answer i
think it's important to emphasize that
we all know there's so many amazing
teachers out there but they often feel
kind of stuck in the rules and um
they're tied with this tied like their
hands are tied a little bit with the
system in place so this is not a knock
on teachers at all there's so many
amazing teachers but in regards to the
public schooling system do you guys see
any problems with it potential
problems i think there's flaws in every
system for sure
that could be school or anything else
and like you said there are incredible
teachers but sometimes yeah they just
don't have enough resources or they have
10 extra kids in their classroom or
whatever it is and they just don't have
time for all the students or
you know we especially right now with so
many kids having missed
you know up to a year of school last
year
and they're you know but some still did
online schooling and so they're doing a
lot of catch-up right now and
um yeah that's just that's that's a lot
for like one teacher in a classroom to
be dealing with and
um
yeah i just think that's difficult even
though i think they're amazing i know
it's not easy i wouldn't want to be no
way taking that on right now it's hard
yeah i mean i used to teach so
the parent not the parent this the
student-to-teacher ratio is real it's a
real thing i would have maybe one or two
kids in class who were
messing around too much and i'm like i
cannot teach like this with all these
children in the class and then there's a
couple who are just like not behaving
properly and still like what do you do
so i would say um the student-to-teacher
ratio is a real um thing and also uh
basically everything that you said um is
everything i i feel and believe too yeah
yeah i sometimes when we're
homeschooling our kids i'm wondering
like how in the world do these teachers
like educate like 30 kids at one time
it's amazing it's actually incredible
it's a lot of work and i really give the
teachers so much respect because they do
love the children most teachers anyways
um some don't want to really teach and
that could i would say that it could be
another problem when the teacher is not
motivated they're maybe they're not
getting paid well totally and it's hard
it's hard to have all these kids and
maybe not enough resources to provide
exactly what you would want for them
that can be a challenge i would say yeah
i think there's a lot of a lot of things
broken within the system that can be
that can definitely be helped and could
be shifted if there was like um an
emphasis towards it but i'm not i'm not
sure if it's going to be changing
anytime soon and i know that there are
plenty of kids who go to public school
and they love their experience so i
think it really just depends on each
child and what what they're needing and
what they desire and i i would love to
send my children to school if as they
age they're wanting to go to school and
finding out okay what are the reasons
you want to go to school and it really
just i think that it's super important
to emphasize like that every child is
different and what's going to be best
for them is like the most important
thing yes so exactly i would like to
test a little bit on that for me i feel
the same way if my kid ever wanted to go
to school because they've been in school
they know what it's like at this point
they don't want to go back to school but
if they ever did i would totally send
them i would look up schools and just
kind of figure out which school
i kind of aligned with and then sent
them i mean the private school that the
kids went to was amazing i really
enjoyed our experience there they got to
do a lot of hands-on things they got to
do gardening they got to experience a
lot
there was a pretty good teacher to
student ratio but you have to pay for
that i would say like in a private
school setting you have to pay a lot of
money for that type of and not everyone
can afford that yeah there's some decent
private schools to i mean public schools
too the one my child went to um
a lot of parents were involved and so
parents would donate money and so they
would have a lot more resources and
maybe a traditional
a regular public school it was kind of
like it was a charter school yeah and it
was in the mountains and it was in
nature and the kids did gardening too
and so there are some great schools and
the teachers i think do um
a great job as well so yeah i think it's
definitely
do what you feel is right for your
family
okay next thing i want to ask is do you
think that the
um
the milestones the public says public
education sets in place is arbitrary or
is there a place for it
the miles like the milestones that we
set in regards to like the grades and
i mean i don't like grading
i i think oh it's hard
uh i'm not one that gives my kids grades
or anything like that um
every child is so different and they
learn different and so
i don't really
enjoy that part of the school um are
they needed
i don't think they're really needed i
guess maybe in high school if they're
trying to go to college or something
it's important but in the lower grade
levels
i don't think it's needed yeah i really
prefer to just let kids learn things at
their own pace
both of my kids were
really slow with their motor skills
they're both really late walkers but
really early talkers
my son was an early reader my daughter
was a late reader and i just appreciated
having the freedom the time in the space
for them to do things at their speed
instead of being like well you're
supposed to learn to read in
kindergarten and you're still struggling
in first grade and
also we have to remember that in a
school classroom
my daughter is born the last week of the
cut-off so she's the youngest in her
grade
so she is a whole year behind
our good friend who is born the first
day of the cut-off
and they are
in very different places
academically in a lot of areas because
there's a year between them
so i
really like that she has the space in
our home
at least for those first few years when
you're still getting such a foundation
um of
you know
reading even that's such a huge thing
i'm so glad that she was able to do it
at her speed and to not feel like a
failure and not feel like you're at the
bottom of the class yes and feel
discouraged because she would have taken
that so hard her tender little heart
just would have been like yes i'm trying
yeah i enjoy reading i'm just not quite
yeah like getting it at the same speed
as these kids and i'm really thankful
that she had this space to be able to
read when she was ready and she was just
like a couple months later and now she
loves reading and is devouring chapter
books right
her timeline was slightly different
right i think that's one of the my
favorite parts about homeschooling is
that children can go at their own pace
and follow whatever they're most excited
about whatever they're naturally
gravitating towards because they tend to
gravitate towards the things they're
really good at too a lot of times and
then they can just excel and get like
years quote-unquote ahead as if compared
to if they were in regular school so i
love that and and the fact that there's
not like a comparison game to all the
other kids that are you know their same
age and technically supposed to be at
the same level so i think that's really
really helpful for their own well-being
and their mental wellness to just focus
on what they're really excited about
yes because i think sometimes they can
get discouraged like in school and
they're comparing themselves to other
kids like oh well i'm not doing that yet
um so and even in homeschooling if
you're around a lot of homeschooling
kids they might do that a little bit
yeah but it's not as much it's not like
right in your face because there's like
you know maybe 25 30 other kids of the
same
age as you in the class and i think uh
sometimes it can become discouraging if
they're be behind in a certain thing but
the beauty of homeschooling is that like
you said you can go at your own pace and
excel in other things that they're
really passionate about
yeah and be way ahead of the game i mean
my my
niko he's like two or three grades ahead
of math
and reading whereas gianni he doesn't he
didn't like reading at first
and so he was a little bit more slower
to come but then now he loves reading
yeah and it's so cool and he wasn't
discouraged by it yeah so i love that
yeah that's not to say that it's bad to
have any kind of competition or natural
inclination to want to like i don't know
just push yourself ahead when you're in
a group that's not it's not like you
want to shun your kids completely from
anything like that
it's more so just like the extreme dogma
that is related to the school system
that can happen for some kids that i
think that is helpful to be aware of and
that's actually something super cool
like you said about homeschool groups
you know when they're around other kids
it it ends up being like this real free
spirit thing where they're all kind of
learning off each other and getting
excited off of different topics yes um
so i want to bring up how i read that
data suggests that approximately 1.2
million families switched to
homeschooling last academic year
bringing the total number of homeschool
students to 3.1 million wow so with
homeschooling on the rise like let's
just talk a little bit about the reasons
now more than ever to homeschool
yeah
i just always go back to the freedom of
it i mean having time with your kids
like that's you know
six to eight hours a day that like
they're
in school and then if they do have
extracurricular activities afterwards
that's a lot of running around for
families so just having that freedom in
your schedule having the freedom to go
at your kids pace um i think my other
favorite thing that i love about
homeschooling is
getting to learn things that weren't
part of the curriculum in in public
school or private school i did a little
of both
um so like my son is really into
survival stuff right now so he's like
building fires and yesterday he had made
some whole water catchment
system like with a wheelbarrow and a
pump and i was like
that's awesome dude i love that like
it's 9am and he's like still in his jam
he's just out there figuring this out
and tinkering around with it and
paige is watering the garden and
um i just love that there's freedom for
them to do that or for them to
learn more about personal finance or
like we just bought a house and they're
like going through that whole process
with them or with us and i'm like i
would have loved to know any of these
things when i came into adulthood like
personal finance how to pay taxes how to
buy a house how to you know
do a lot of these things and maybe those
are taught in some schools i don't maybe
i just missed them but no i i was not
taught that stuff in high school
elementary for sure yeah i would have
appreciated a little more of that
personally
well i think a lot more people are
starting to homeschool because of what's
been going on the past couple years with
the pandemic i know a lot of people have
struggled with trying to do it at home
with virtually with the teacher
there and then sometimes they get to go
in and sometimes not and then sometimes
they do and they have to wear the mask
all day long and so i think that the
stability is not there for the kids
right now and i know
parents who send their kids to school
have have expressed that to me how
it's a little challenging right now so i
think homeschooling i mean when the
pandemic happened it really wasn't a
huge shift or change for us it was like
we were already homeschooling and so
that was pretty cool and our kids um
just kept doing what they've been doing
and didn't have to
you know do the online type school stuff
and just kept on doing what they were
doing and i think a lot of parents
nowadays they're seeing that and they
kind of want that freedom and
flexibility to do that also so that's
something to think about with everything
going on in the world right now yes i
think both of those things you said like
everything that's happening in the world
and just um the restrictions that
they've had with their with their
learning that what they were used to
being able to go to school before
without all these um restrictions and
things like that and what happened with
them being at home and
um there was so much suffering i think
with kids just like tied to a screen by
themselves all day while you know
parents a lot of them had to be at work
and so i can't even imagine and then
also the ability to teach your children
really practical things and for them
just be immersed in
things that they would experience in the
real world that we wish we would have
been taught ourselves that aren't like
unit curriculums
in school but like probably should be um
i think it also reminds me another thing
that john holt had said about how how
amazing children learn when they're with
someone who's passionate about something
and how quickly they take on whatever
that specific topic is the person that's
passionate about it reminds me of when
my kids were
at my dad's house so their grandpa and
we were in california they were in the
backyard and my dad was really excited
about composting at the time and they
were in the backyard he was just showing
them all the things and my dad loves to
explain everything in really gruesome
detail and just take everything step by
step and show them how to do something
and they were just so excited about it
and immersed into it and it's that type
of daily thing where they're
with adults who are excited about things
whatever they're passionate about
and i think that's something really
important that we can make sure to do as
homeschoolers that give you that added
benefit of homeschooling is immersing
them with other adults who are
passionate about things and they learn
so much from that and the other thing i
think is a lot of parents are starting
to become concerned about the types of
things that children are learning in
school even some things that are
starting to some agenda type things that
are being put forth in school and that
doesn't mean it's always the case but
there are certain examples of that
happening and so people are kind of
doing this call to action homeschool
type thing like you know so you can
educate your children in a way that you
know is is best for their development
um
okay so next i want to get into breaking
down a few different parenting
philosophies um for the schooling
philosophy yes homeschooling philosophy
my last name my last my last episode was
a parenting episode so you know that was
just yesterday um but a few different
homeschooling philosophies um for those
who are looking to homeschool but they
don't know where to start they don't
know like what the differences are like
maybe they have in their head that
there's one way to do it but there's
actually so many different ways to
homeschool and tailor it based on your
child's needs so yeah let's get into
that i think it would be good to talk
about unschooling a lot of people don't
know what that is um and then we can
talk about a more structured kind of the
opposite end of like maybe online
schooling or very just like curriculum
based schooling and then somewhere in
between and talk about different couple
philosophies from there so do one of you
guys get i want to go first i'm gonna do
the unschooling sure um
i think unschooling i think all of these
things can look like a lot of different
ways right um unschooling can look like
our child will figure out how to read
when they decide to
you know just kind of like parents are
super hands-off
um
so that's one example of um unschooling
that i think is kind of the thing that
people think of when they hear that word
still you know this extreme example
they've maybe seen on tv or something
um for us it's just a little more
free and open and child-led so we don't
have a curriculum
and we just kind of go off of whatever
the next thing the next natural thing
for them to learn
would be so some days i might write a
handful of things on our whiteboard like
these are some things i'd like to do
today
and we might get through two of them or
we might do them all and more and some
days we might just be like
completely scratched that list and
they're like so focused in
you know like we did this like herbal
medicine course and they're like let's
go out and find these so we're like
scratch you know the whole schedule you
know scrap the plans for the day and
just like we're gonna go out and forage
and like make a tincture when we get
home and just having that flexibility to
just set aside
what we thought our plans were going to
be and follow wherever their interests
are because like you said when they're
excited about something and they're like
passionate about it and they see i'm
excited about it because i geek out on
that stuff they're like let's keep going
like you know so they've created this
hole and then they want to create this
whole like fairy herb garden at home and
they're like naming all the fairy's
plant names and they're just like
getting super into it so
for us unschooling is just being able to
follow those curiosities follow those
passions
and making time and space for the kids
to lead
um wherever they want
perfect yeah and so i think the opposite
end of the spectrum would be more like a
box curriculum or like an online school
type of thing so box curriculum is you
find a curriculum that you like you get
it and then you just follow exactly what
it says
and then for online school um there's
different programs that you can do one
of them that might our friends do is
called aselus online and i talked to her
a little bit about it and she says her
kids do about four hours of school a day
so um four days a week so 16 hours a
week and then
they actually advance the whole grade
level just by doing that so she thinks
that's more than enough
for them to do so it's all online they
have
videos that they watch and learn from
online and i think that's really good
for parents who maybe
don't want to
do specific things with them or don't
know what to do
and they just want someone else to do it
that's a good way to um to do
homeschooling is the online school the
box curriculum is um
is great too it's a great
tool to have we love
the good and the beautiful curriculum i
got a bunch of their stuff and i also
use it i don't per say follow and do it
every single day exactly as it as they
say but i love having it as a resource
and that's what you can also do too i
think that's kind of the middle ground i
would say more like that i'm kind of
like the eclectic approach and
just the middle ground having all the
resources that i can lots of books lots
of hands-on things i love subscription
boxes um different curriculums different
workbooks because my kids actually do
like workbooks which is funny i was all
against them in the beginning but no you
can't do a workbook
but they were drawn to them and love
them like okay i guess i'll get it for
you so there's fun ones like the star
wars math books they just love my kids i
love the star wars workbooks so fun so
they've created lots of different um
educational resources lakeshore learning
is another really good resource for
supplies and rainbow resources there's a
lot
and so the middle ground i would say is
kind of picking a philosophy of yours
let's say it's charlotte mason charlotte
mason they do a lot of art studies
narration um being in nature a lot and
so you can kind of take that philosophy
and then find resources that you like
that go ahead and go along with that
philosophy if that makes sense
yeah perfect okay i think that's a good
way to explain it a lot of people i
think when they hear unschooling they
think like if we're going back to the
first one that they must think like oh
well what if the kid just wants to watch
tv all day right and then you just don't
do anything or they can a lot of people
also assume
that um school is like school time and
then after school is like not school not
learning time but really living is
learning and you can take an approach
where you maybe you want to do a
curriculum or you're like inspired by
certain creative resources like joseph
was talking about um or maybe you're
even doing this online schooling that
she was talking about originally but you
also can make sure to be aware and
incorporate and realize that living is
learning so throughout everything that
they're doing throughout the day look
for ways on what what are they
interested in and how can we provide
information and give them the resources
that they need to help them learn even
more and and it's really just like about
everything that they do children want to
be like big people they want to learn
how to be like us and so everything
about them and their spirit loves
learning at a young age and it isn't
until a lot of times when they get older
that they think this is learning well i
don't like learning you know if it comes
to going to a regular school and that's
like we said earlier not every kid every
kid is different
like joseph i love school my sister
loves school i on the other hand when i
got to school i was like this is
learning
i hate learning
i hate sitting in a desk all day and
being told what to do
and you know walking down the hall and
having all these rules and i was always
getting in trouble even though i was
like not a i was i was like a totally
perfectly normal i mean normal isn't the
word but i was just getting trouble all
the time i just didn't like having the
rules and so in my head that's what
learning was and i'm like i don't like
learning but as a kid we love learning
and so just realizing that like every
every opportunity that you see
throughout the day is is a place for
learning and you can expand that and
give them re the resources that's what's
so beautiful so even if you're watching
this and maybe you're inspired by
homeschooling but you're just not there
yet or you don't have the ability to
homeschool you can realize that outside
of the home when you are with your
children you still have that opportunity
to do things with them where they're
learning in an you know unschooling
approach where you can just provide
whatever they're excited excited about
absolutely i would say even when my
children were in school
when they got home we were doing
activities and fun things we would go to
the library we'd go to museums we'd go
wherever um they wanted really that was
educational and fun they can learn so
just because your child is in school too
doesn't mean you can't do
um some interest lead type of learning
at home when they are home right you
know and i think it's perfect because
that will kind of ignite passions in
them and help them figure out what i
want to be when i grow up what do i want
to do with my future i mean i didn't
know what i wanted to do until i was
like in college so we have plenty of
time
don't worry about that um
yeah yeah so good and then you also are
inviting them into life skills so like
you're saying just making everything we
call everything school so my kids get
confused and people ask what's your
favorite subject cause like yesterday
they did toilet school they had to
replace the pump in the toilet with dad
and i'm like now they know how to do
that
but if someone's like what'd you do
today like toilet school
um you know where we had our foster baby
we just called that season like baby
school like they learned how to like
make the bottles and change the diapers
and all about the foster care system and
and so many other things i just feel
like if you invite them into the
everyday things that you're doing
you are
doing school you're educating them
you're teaching them and if they
come out of 12th grade with like a whole
lot of life skills
that's amazing and i mean they're going
to learn other things too you know like
we're in an era of information
everything and anything we want to know
is at our fingertips but um it's the
life skills that i feel like is kind of
lacking sometimes in kids these days yes
i think that's such a good point because
a lot of times children are kind of
looked at as this like side prop where
it's like oh you know they went to
school they came home now just do your
own thing and while i have to do all my
own things but when you integrate
you know your life with your kids
they're learning so much with everything
that you're doing something as simple as
like your husband you know fixing the
toilet a lot of people might just be
inclined to be like get out leave the
room i need to be alone in peace but um
just like humbling yourself and slowing
life down and just letting them be
involved in it they learn so much yes it
kind of reminds me of like with cooking
sometimes i just want to be in the
kitchen by myself doing what i want to
do i'll do it way quicker but you know
nico the other day he like really wanted
to learn how to cook some things and so
he was like okay let's get out a
cookbook why don't you pick one out and
you write down some recipes which ones
you want to do so he got grabbed the
cookbook went through it and kind of
picked out a few recipes that he wanted
to learn and then cooked it completely
on his own he made french toast and it
was so cute i loved it
and he learned a life skill so he's i'm
like you're gonna know how to cook when
you're older yeah and and i think it's
so great also um
we go to library a lot and that's where
you can help your kid find their little
passions and interests too because
they'll go through all the books kind of
pick out things that they're interested
in gianni we would we just went recently
and he is in love with uh learning about
cats right now cougars and and pumas and
i don't even know the names of different
ones and so we got all the books and
started learning about them and then he
did art art for kids hub is that what
it's called
a class online and he drew the cougar
and then i actually found
another program called out school if you
guys aren't familiar with it it's a
great resource to have as parents um
they do classes online and so gianni
wanted to do a class where each each
class was about a different cat
not something i am into or interested in
but he loves it and i'm like go for it
and he really loved it and he's in there
with a few other kids and the teacher is
so bubbly and fun and got to learn about
some cats so that's so cool
okay so let's talk a little bit about
like as the kids are getting a little
older what kind of opportunities for
maybe parents at home going what can i
provide for my children to where they
can get out and do the things maybe in
the real world that you're not an expert
on um but like they can gain some really
amazing experiences
with other people and what they're
learning like for me i think about how
like right now currently our kids are in
like baseball league every year and
scout's doing ballet and now she's just
starting gymnastics but there's also
this benefit to
um balancing and not being so obsessed
with all these extra curricular
activities so it's really there's a
weird balance there where like sometimes
life is all about the hustle and like
just get them in all the things but then
there's also the hey let's slow it down
and like pick one or two things at a
time so obviously i just mentioned like
sports but like other things like
internships and um i think about another
example of um our friend's daughter
charlie she's like 14 now i think or
maybe 15 and she's like at this it's a
community center where um she gets to
you know be a part of a radio a radio
show and like cooking and
doing kind of cooking classes and making
an e-book and it's that type of stuff
that i think is really because they have
the time to go do those types of things
whereas they might not have that time if
they're in regular school and they get
home and they have all that homework and
maybe don't have as much time to do
things like that so maybe do you guys
have any other ideas of different kinds
of ways to get into internships or
different things like that as they get
older i know our kids aren't quite at
that age yet but
well i think taking it take not
advantage but making use of your
community looking around i mean we have
so many so many talented people in our
community um you for example are one hey
you want to start a podcast i'm going to
send you to ellen yeah and you know he
can come and learn from you and and
things like that so i think taking a
look at who's in your community
if they want if they love flowers
there's flower farm right down the
street take them there ask them hey do
you want to do a little collaboration
can we come and you can help teach them
about um
about planting flowers
and they can learn all about it yeah
so i think finding people in your
community
is key
yeah yeah absolutely perfect okay cool i
think that we wrapped up kind of that
beginning like the
just the wholeness of what it can be all
the different ways and i kind of wanted
to get into some common questions people
have and you guys can just answer
um the first one is a lot of people ask
when do i start
how do i start homeschooling and like
when like at what age
i think that like you said earlier
homeschooling is kind of a lifestyle or
almost like a parenting style so it can
start when they're two and three and
starting to ask questions and instead of
being like i don't know i don't know
it's like what do you think or
let's look that up what do ducks eat you
know or you're shopping at target and
there's the letter t
can we look for some other teas while
we're shopping and sometimes those
things can feel like i have to make a
little more effort but once you start
doing it and it's just kind of your
second nature to engage with your kids
like that then they're learning
everywhere they go and with everything
they're doing with you
so i think in that way learning starts
as soon as
you have a child
yeah
um
we started a um curriculum in first
grade because it was a waldorf-based
curriculum and that's
traditionally when waldorf starts his
first grade um but before that for like
preschool and kindergarten ages we just
made like a goal list for the year so it
might be like tie their shoes learn to
swim
uh learn to spell their name just kind
of whatever was you know relevant to
that specific kid and i would just refer
back to my list every few weeks or
months or however often and that was
just kind of the
the list our little like goal list that
we went off of that year i love that
yeah and it's so true when it comes to
them being young integrating them into
your everyday things like shopping yeah
and it's easy to just be like sit quiet
you know be quiet while i just do the
shopping but when you um engage with
them and let them you know do it with
you they they become empowered and
they're more likely to be excited to
learn as well because you're empowering
them absolutely i think um
i i was laughing because i'm like yeah
right out of the womb
i feel like you can just start engaging
with your child sing songs to them
seeing the abcs and it naturally kind of
just goes in their brain and they just
start remembering it
i remember nico actually um i'd never
even taught him my phone number but we
would go to this restaurant and you get
like a little discount if you say your
phone number and you put it in anyways
um he he remembered it like that i'm
like so funny but um anyway
incorporating um i think you can start
at any age really right when they're
born but compulsory education though
there there are rules for that so i
would take a look at what your rules are
for your state because i think for
hawaii i think it's six you like have to
school so you either have to put them in
school
or um you can homeschool and there's
different laws and rules so um there's a
great website it's the h i wrote it down
hslda.org
and it's a great resource for finding
requirements like for your state and
even i think it has things for different
countries as well um so for if you're
getting started with homeschooling
excellent resource to go on there and
find out what are the laws for your
state there are actually some countries
that you cannot homeschool it's like
wow and so
i would definitely take a look at that
and see what you can um if you could
homeschool yeah that's really helpful
for people to look into thank you for
sharing that website because then they
can learn at what age they need to
enroll their kids for like online um
or just to the public system like
showing that you are homeschooling
because that is really important
important
um so what are your thoughts on parents
who want to homeschool their children
but they feel like they aren't certified
in anything and they're not experts in
certain subjects and they want to be
able to properly educate their children
but they're like i just i'm not maybe
smart enough in their brain maybe
they're saying that what are your
thoughts on that
i think
we all
uh can feel like that at times but i
would say
don't let fear be a reason for you to
not homeschool if you can parent if you
can be a mom you can homeschool
so i would say don't allow fear to stop
you from that talk to other moms in your
area who homeschool connect with
different people
and and just tell yourself you know what
i can do this and there's so many
resources nowadays to help um parents
um to homeschool that i think uh you
don't have to let fear send in the way
compare i know people can compare oh man
jenna does all these amazing things i
know sometimes i'm like man jenna does
some really cool stuff
but i think like every every family is
unique and different and that's the
beauty of it normally what happens is um
you're going to start doing things in
your home that you're kind of passionate
about a little bit and they'll learn
like toilet things
i don't know anything about a door
either or building things but you know
um i think
don't worry about that don't worry about
comparing yourself to other people
there's lots of people online and you
can tend to do that
don't do it
because you look within yourself and
know that you are unique and special and
you know what's best for your children
if you go off of that you're going to be
good
that's beautiful yeah i think also
remembering like
no one knows everything
like
we all have
i like to think we all have maybe like a
good solid like fifth or sixth grade
education in most areas and then we
excel in our specific areas right like
there was a show or something like are
you smarter than a fifth grader right
and my son is in fifth grade right now
so i'm like
wow yeah there's a lot of us i don't
think remember some of these things and
that's okay like you have your certain
areas you excel in and then
they get to see you learning alongside
them and i love that like my kids know
that i don't know every single thing
like they know i'm reading from you know
a book or looking something up i'm like
i don't know let's look that up let's
research that together and i think
that's beautiful and healthy because
then they're seeing an example of a
lifelong learner
because that's what i want them to be i
want them to not think that they have to
go around with all the answers i want
them to sit and say tell me more about
that or i love to research that more
and so
for them to see that in us i think is
awesome i don't think they need to need
a parent who knows everything yes i
think learned that that's beautifully
said i was actually going to say the
same thing it's really really amazing
for your kids to see you wanting to
engage and learn with them which is what
we end up doing all the time i'm always
like learning this with them like let's
look this up let's figure it out
together and they might come to me be
like mom did you know this about that
i'm like i didn't know wow and we're
like trying to figure it out together
and you're so right creating a lifelong
learner is is
exampling that to them
is really powerful and it's also
wonderful to realize that you might
excel in one thing and then if the
things that they really want to learn
that you're you don't know how to do and
you can't just look it up
um you can hire out for that type of
thing or do even exchanges with other
people with other homeschooled parents
being like hey i know you're really
great at this like can you teach my
child this i'll teach your child this if
they're interested
that type of thing as well an example is
that um my husband grew up learning all
of the kids and their family each
learned a different instrument
growing up and andrew's like okay i'm
i'm thinking that the kids we could
start them on an instrument soon i know
that your kids do as well a little bit
with yours right
i mean beatboxing right yes oh my gosh
nico's a great beatboxer but elvis was
starting to show an interest in wanting
to get a keyboard and so andrew's like
all right let's get the kids different
instruments right now sandy is just he
was thinking he wanted to learn the
violin and andrew can't teach him the
violin he's like i could teach him the
saxophone i could teach him um the
keyboard or a guitar so right now we're
just going to do the keyboard and let
sandy and elvis work on the keyboard and
if sandy is still showing an interest
like okay i also want to do the violin
then we can hire out for that type of
thing so
that's exactly i think taking advantage
of the resources around you um we have a
family whose
daughter she's really into um singing
and she sings so cute and she plays the
keyboard producing and
i'm like where did she learn that and
they have a music teacher so then i'm
like okay can i have their contact info
and then that's what you do you just
contact them say hey can you come teach
my child also i think it's awesome math
when it starts getting like harder i'm
like
i don't know about that yeah hiring a
tutor can be beneficial to that there's
also online classes nico the other day
he's like mom can i do a class online
for for math
like really you want to do that okay oh
you can try it so i'm going to look up a
class um on out school for math and so
there's a lot of resources that we can
use to kind of help our children when we
may not um know it at the time perfect
yes totally okay another i think
probably one of the most common
questions people have at home schooling
which is something we kind of already
talked about but let's just talk about a
little further is do home-schooled kids
lack socialization
not that i've seen no
but that was totally the stigma growing
up i remember even myself growing up
thinking oh the homeschool kids are the
weird ones and someone pointed out to me
this is kind of funny but someone was
like i don't think that it's that
homeschooling made them weird it's just
that the families who tend to homeschool
tend to be weird
which wasn't that great which was that i
think it was a lot different back when
we were growing up rather than now it's
exploded a lot more people see benefits
to homeschooling um at least for even
just a period of time in their life so
yeah why don't you just explain a little
to help really people to nail in the
coffin there's this like stigma that
homeschool kids lack socialization but
that just has not been any of our
experiences at all
i think your kids are as socialized as
you let them be you know like
i i grew up mostly in public school and
i was very unsocialized you know i had a
lot of childhood trauma and was rudely
shy
for
most of
basically until i got married so
i
i don't think that home or um public
school is what like socialized me it was
because of my own personality or what i
had been through my own family growing
up
um
but my kids are with friends every
single day like we have to have days
we're like let's have a friend break
because it's a little too much sometimes
and i i don't think that it comes down
to where your children are educated for
how socialized they are it's it's just
about
if you're giving them opportunity to
have
friends and social skills and
and also i think that there's this myth
with socialization that they need to be
around peers of the exact same age
which is crazy because that's like we're
all different ages in this room and
my son plays with the neighbor my son is
11. he plays with the neighbor kid who's
four and he can play with the other kid
who's 15 and he can have a conversation
with my aunt who came over yesterday and
and he can talk to people of all ages
because that's normal life that's real
life yeah i want him to be able to not
only be really good at talking to other
11 year olds
i want him to be able to talk to anyone
yes he comes in contact with and get on
their level right depending on who
they're like they can morph into whoever
they're around like seeing my eldest
elvis who's 10 when he's around babies
and toddlers and how you just get on
their level he's so used to being around
babies and it's not like this you know
not cool thing right
maybe it'll get different once he got
old it gets older but he he loves it and
just seeing how when he's around older
kids how he adjusts and or even adults
and how he just becomes this like little
adult
and socializing with them it makes me
think of
when we had dr clapper visiting
for the podcast how when i was setting
up for the podcast elvis wanted to make
dr clapper a salad and tea and so we
made it and set it all up for him and
while i was setting up he invited dr
clapper over to sit on the deck while i
was setting up the podcast here and they
had this whole
you know conversation and throughout the
whole trip he was conversing with them
by the end dr clapper was like this
kid's amazing like he's like give him my
email so we can go back and forth on
emails and if you ever have a question
about and he was teaching him all these
amazing things about human anatomy and
you know medical stuff and it was so
cool just
and if he was at school all day he
wouldn't have gotten that experience to
be around a medical doctor who has a
wealth of knowledge in his field anyways
yeah i don't think that
socialization is a problem i mean
they're very very rare like you said if
there's in the cabin in the woods and no
one else around yeah but that's not what
i've seen and noticed i actually think
uh being around lots of different kids
of different ages i mean nico loves
colfax
so cute they have a special little
bonner relationship and and i think it
helps them to um
learn how to interact with kids of
different ages even adults and there's
so many opportunities for socialization
too like whether it be a homeschool
group if you wanted to do that
there's a wild and free which is a
really great website and resource too
you can look up and join a wild and free
group if let's say you want homeschool
community you can find it that way
also sports sports is another way to
provide i guess a social experience
experience with your child um doing
baseball soccer football whatever sport
your child's into
they get to play with kids their age and
just have a good time so i think there's
lots of opportunity for socialization
and i think even for me i think it's a
little more because we have a little bit
more freedom and flexibility to just say
hey let's go to the skate park with some
friends and then we just go or let's go
to the beach
with some friends during like the school
day and they get that time there where
when they went to school they did get um
breaks for that like recess and lunch
but the rest of the time they're in
classic learning and have to focus on
that
whereas um i think at home you do um
homeschool it doesn't take as many hours
for home school yes so we do it you know
from about ten to one four days a week
and then the rest of the time we're able
to do whatever we want and that's also
flexible too let's say we wanted to go
on a field trip somewhere to um
with friends then we would do that
during the school day so a lot i love
the freedom and flexibility of that yeah
you made such a good point about how you
can get so much more done in such a
short amount of time because you're
focused on your children just the you
know the few kids that you have as
opposed to a teacher that has to teach
30 children and has to go at a certain
pace they're not able to get as much
done in a day as with when you're at
home with your kids so then after you
get it done quicker you have you know
the you know quote unquote get it done
because you're really learning about all
different kinds of things but when you
do like more sit-down stuff at home with
them then you have the rest of the day
to go and do lots of different things
so another common question people have
is how do you keep your kids motivated
like what do you do if your kids don't
want to homeschool what if they're like
consistently just resisting and just not
wanting to do it and maybe part of it is
because you're their mom right it's not
the same as if they had like um a
different peer who was teaching them so
how do you how do you handle that if
your kid just consistently doesn't want
to do any kind of homesplain like nah i
just want to do it i don't want to do
anything
i mean i would say for the most part
my kids are pretty motivated to learn
because we're doing things that they're
interested in
although there are some times where i
want to incorporate something that i
want them maybe peak their interest and
they're like wait a minute what is this
um
but um or a hard let's say a harder
level of math let's say
than they want to do
um i'm like okay do they really
like just not want to challenge
themselves you know or do they really
just don't want to do it and so um i i
do encourage them i say you know you can
do hard things
and so maybe you may not know this math
problem right now but that's you don't
have to you're not supposed to
that's why i'm helping guide you to
learn um
and so once they get it they're like oh
my gosh i love this it's so cool
so i think if you can keep the um
interest-led type of thing going
that definitely helps and also there's
going to be some days i mean we all have
our days when we're in different moods i
think sometimes you can just take a
little break go out in nature i think
nature is the best medicine
um helps them to get more free and while
maybe they need to do a wrestling break
i know my boys they love to wrestle
they're very active oh my gosh so hey
take a little wrestling break um
so i think there's different uh ways to
help also
i do tell them
how good they got it
i'm like do you know
how good you have it here um and then
they remember and they're like oh yeah
i want i want to keep homeschooling yeah
and so yeah just encouraging them with
uh positive words and or just reminding
them and then doing something fun with
them of things that they're interested
in
it's good i think um changing it up too
can help sometimes if there's a subject
that's maybe not as interesting or an
area where they feel stuck like okay
let's change our approach we don't have
to just teach it this way at the desk on
this paper like let's go out and find a
way to
do that math in nature or find out a way
to
you know make this story stick let's act
it out instead or whatever it is you
know just like use your creativity it
doesn't have to be some elaborate
pinterest project but like you said even
just getting out in nature like we're
going to take this book out to the beach
or we're going to you know go do this
after we go on a little hike or
something um just kind of changing your
environment or your approach can be
really helpful love that that's all so
helpful for us we kind of have like
certain things right that we're learning
and we have our projects that we do that
i'll do with them um
once a week and then andrew does these
throughout the rest of the days where he
does like curriculum and sometimes he'll
do projects with them too but on certain
days when they're just not feeling it
they're like i don't want to do my math
book i don't want to do my reading and
that type of thing and she'll be like
okay pick whatever you want to learn
about i'm gonna and then he'll if
they're like really struggling still
like i don't even know what he'll be
like all right here's four things that
he knows they would want to learn about
he's like we could learn about the
toilet sanitation system and they're
like
like
what anything toilet i don't know why
it's like sanitation is so interesting
to children like the toilet um public
system or he's like or we can learn
about alien theories and he'll be like
or we can learn and he'll just pick the
most random things and then they pick
one and it's like the whole day is just
like looking up alien theories and like
they're just so into it all of a sudden
they're really back and they're pumped
about their about learning because it's
like look at these are the different
things and this is what people look at
these are the so-called ufo sightings
and here and they'll just go into all of
it and it'll be something so random like
i'll come back from work and i'm like
you learned about toilets all day
hey but we wrote about it yeah we drew a
little yes drawing exactly they do this
whole long paragraph journal about it
they draw pictures and it's like just
this all-encompassing fun experience for
them and then the next day they're like
okay yeah i'm ready for math books
i think it's cool to incorporate things
you're passionate about with multiple
subjects like you know um when gianni
wants to uh doesn't he's not a huge fan
of writing but when it's something that
he's passionate about then he'll do it
so we bought these cute little um books
and we do the author day every year and
they can create their own story and they
get really pumped and excited about that
and they'll write an entire book
you know and i think that's what they're
passionate about and it's cool and it
helps get them writing so doing
something like that is a really fun way
to make it fun and interesting yes and
then they get to see what they did at
the end of it this huge project they did
at their book and their drawings and
their story
yes we've done that multiple times like
with our homeschool group and even just
on our own and like the kids love
looking back at their like own homemade
books that they got to do
um
okay so the next question would be like
do you need to have a schedule so we did
kind of talk about how it's like it
could be free flow it could be
um
like rigid so
i guess it really just is what you what
you make of it is there anything you
want to add to that
um i think
it can be different in different seasons
when we had our foster babe in the house
for over a year
we squeezed a lot into a little bit of
time you know it was we weren't really
on a schedule like okay she's asleep
let's let's do some homeschool or
or she's at a visitation let's get some
stuff done
um but now that my kids are older like
kind of later elementary school
um
in the season that we are in we kind of
thrive on a little bit more of a
schedule so it might just be like oh
from like kind of like you said from
this time to this time we're gonna focus
on some sort of school stuff and it
might look really loose and free-flowing
or we might be sitting down writing
something on a paper or doing math or
something
but that time having like at least that
chunk of our day that's dedicated
to
school um is helpful for us and it also
keeps us like i said our neighborhood
can get very social so it keeps from
like the 8 am like knocks on the door
it's like so they know just like after 2
o'clock we can play for hours right but
just kind of having like that devoted
time even if it's not like every single
minute or hour
has an assigned
task or subject yes exactly i'm similar
i am we have kind of like a routine i
think routines are important like a
strict rigid schedule you don't have to
have but some people thrive on that too
so i think do what's best for your
family um for me i do like having a
routine and so we have a routine monday
through thursday from 10 to one we're
going to kind of focus on some things
now is it super rigid where i'm like
from this time this time we're doing
this from this not really um we do start
off with like usually like snack and
story time and then we'll get into
topics of interest and then kind of go
from there but i like to leave a room
for curiosity and fun and
um like if they want to go a library or
something all right let's go to the
library um so it's not like super rigid
but i think it's important to have for
me a routine to kind of know um what so
the children can expect it like this is
what we're doing during this time and i
think it kind of helps um create less
behavior problems too i think because
they kind of expect it and know
that it's it's at this time when we're
doing it and and they get plant so much
free time in the morning too they're
just like we start a little bit later
you're probably an earlier starter
but um
i think pick what works for you and your
family i know some families who um do it
like later in the evening you know or
even on the weekends
so i think go with what works for you
and you don't have to have a super
strict schedule but i think a routine is
good to have
yeah that's a good point i like what you
said too about how sometimes some
families can even choose to homeschool
on the weekends like maybe if their
partner is not working and so it's
easier to do it with your partner if
that's even a possibility that's
something i've never even even
considered
we start our homeschooling a little bit
later in the day we like to do it slow
have slow mornings you know eat
breakfast lazily play with the kids
and i think about how if we were at
school we'd have to hustle so fast out
the door especially with the four kids
that we have i'm like man the days that
we do have to get out of the house early
i'm like oh this is exhausting yeah let
alone to do that every day yes that's
one of my favorite things about
homeschooling is the slow mornings
because i was there when i had to get
them there by a certain time and i'd be
like okay we gotta hurry up and eat and
it wasn't i was just like oh i'm tired
yeah and then all the driving i have to
do was like so much driving um so i love
that that we get to have the slow
mornings and relax actually make a good
breakfast and then i don't have to pack
a whole lunch to send them to school i
kind of like that i get to cook at home
right and yeah have that slower time
with them yeah i think that can be
really healthy for kids not just be so
hustle hustle hustle all the time with
this fast-paced world that we've made
and just let them be you know children
and not have to be so rushed every
single day
so are there any surprising benefits to
homeschooling that you didn't expect
i think it's been really healing for me
um
i
kind of grew up fast as a kid and
although i mostly enjoyed school or i'm
like i feel like i'm the personality
type that school was made for like i'm
studious i was very teacher's pet and i
always tried to get like the straight
a's
i always did kind of feel like this like
round peg and a square or however that i
think i did that backwards anyway um but
i felt like it just didn't quite fit in
there and um
i kind of missed
a lot and i kind of missed some of this
like wonder and
curiosity that is supposed to be part of
childhood so i think a surprising thing
for me has been like how like beautiful
and healing is for me to like learn
alongside my kids and like
do art or like things and i'm like i
don't have time for art like
i have to like
mop a floor or something responsible but
um being able to just like have this
dedicated time that we're like doing
something or learning a new skill
um so much of the time as adults we
don't set aside time for ourselves to
learn something new but being able to
like join my kids and that like you know
i'm in the school program right now for
myself and being able to even kind of
bring them into some of the schooling
i'm doing and like we have this time to
like we have time today to learn
something is really cool i think that
um that's been my biggest surprise how
much i've really enjoyed it in a way
that i didn't expect
yeah i don't have an elaborate answer i
would just say i'm surprised that i'm
still homeschooling
because i i'm telling you i did never
pictured myself homeschooling so to eat
i think the surprise was that i enjoyed
it and loved it and wanted to continue
doing it
and that your kids loved it and that my
kids loved it yes for me it's just
seeing how much how exciting how excited
they are at the things that we're doing
like it's so cool to have it seeing it
play out compared to like in my head
when i was like maybe pregnant with my
first kid like oh i'm totally gonna home
school i think you know maybe i'll send
them to school when they're older if
they want to go to school but i would
love to start out homeschooling and then
just seeing it in reality and like how
it is now and just how excited the kids
get about these new things and different
things that we're learning it's really
special
and that they get to be with their dad
too part of that is because we do have
andrew at home and so they're learning a
lot from both of us which is really cool
so what about someone who wants to
homeschool but they feel like
financially constrained or if both
parents are working or something is
there any way that parents can swing it
if they have some constraints like that
i think there's a few different ideas i
have in mind um because
i think i take it back to when um i was
working full-time and i really wanted to
be a stay-at-home mom
and my husband was like no but you have
a great job and
you have that income coming in how are
you going to do it without it and so
what i did was i basically rewrote a
budget with just his income and
we just lived like that for about a year
or two it took me two years to finally
make the decision like okay we can do
this and i can stay at home at home
school so i would say
really take a look at the budget because
there are certain things in your budget
you think that our
needs but their wants like new clothes
for example that is a want that's not a
need you can get things
used or hand-me-downs or things like
that um
let's see i can't think of anything else
right now but there's lots of things
that you can look at in your budget to
see what can i take out what is not a
want i mean what is not a need
okay and then so so take a look at that
and then if you really still can't swing
it maybe working part-time maybe you can
work part-time and then spend some of
those hours with your child um another
idea i would say is
if you if you really want to homeschool
but let's say you can't maybe you can
have um somebody else homeschool your
children ask a friend ask a fan member
ask somebody else who's already
homeschooling if they are able to do it
um maybe you can pay them a little bit
um
or do an exchange or do an exchange or
something like that i had another idea
but i can't think of it right now so
i'll let you know
um i was gonna say what you already said
so that's great um checking out your
budget is really good um i also read a
book a few years ago called the five
hour school week i can't remember the
name of the author i don't know you guys
have read it um
it was just really encouraging and just
kind of that like reminder of they don't
you don't need
six to eight hours a day to teach your
kid like they're not in a classroom of
of 20 or 30 kids like you get this
concentrated time with them
and so you don't
like if you do work part-time or even a
full-time job i have a friend that works
a full-time job and she just does her
homeschool with the kids on the weekends
and has like family and friends that
help out during the week but
i just think that if something is really
important to you and it's a value to you
and it doesn't have to be but if it is
like there's always a creative solution
you know and it doesn't need to look
like it does for you or me or you
like
it's it can it can look a hundred
different ways yeah that's perfect
another thing i was going to say i
remembered was if you can do a work from
home type of job
that could be helpful too um you know do
a little bit of work get a little break
do a little home school and also you
don't have to have the same hours as
school yeah you can do it after work
hours also and like you said just find
someone who can maybe take care of your
children during the day
or something like that so
different ways and then if you really
really can't
i think just finding a school that you
kind of align with and love and then
just sending them there you know
yes and just tackling on a little bit
what you said about the exchange thing
or just having someone else homeschool
your kids too you could also do like a
twice a week kind of swap things like
hey so you take my kids twice a week
i'll take your kids twice a week and
we'll homeschool each other's kids um so
that way maybe if you have a part-time
job you can still be able to do both
like that yes that's a great idea yeah
that's awesome
okay so are there any cons to
homeschooling
not enough time to myself
oh my gosh i would say that's the
biggest con for me but
that's why i think it's so important to
set aside that time for yourself so that
you can get rejuvenated and do things
that you're also passionate and and that
you love too i think that's the biggest
challenge i would say for me is um
making time for myself and so i do make
it a priority though and i put it in the
schedule and i make the time to spend
with my friends because that really
helps me um to just get rejuvenated
again it's good
nothing is coming to mind right now i'll
let you know if something comes up
i think i think probably uh a con would
be like you said like it there's not
much time for yourself as much um but
for the for
oh gosh i don't know i'm trying to think
what what could it be if something comes
to mind i think i'll
i think another thing though that could
be a challenge for people is
is um
sometimes let's say your kids are being
very emotional and misbehaving and i
think they do that more so at home
because they're comfortable with you and
i think that's great and they make they
wouldn't act like that like at school
with the teacher but with you they will
because they're just more comfortable
around you and so i think it's that can
be a challenge at times when they're
going through big emotions and
maybe behavior difficulties and so i try
to take it as like okay this is a great
learning opportunity for me see what can
i do to help my child express these big
emotions
and um and it helps it's helped me grow
like so much i think i've learned
just as much if not more in this journey
of homeschooling um my children and and
that's one of the things i've definitely
been learning and i'm not perfect at it
at all um but definitely has helped me
to grow yes for sure for sure that's
such a good point i'm so glad you said
that um so i have a couple more common
questions i think but before i get into
that i think it would be helpful to
explain a little bit about the different
types of subjects that you can teach
your children that are so wide and far
range other than just the you know five
like subjects that they learn in school
you know you think typical like math
science history
you know english type of things like
what other types of things can children
explore through homeschooling outside of
that i mean so many things i think
like quinn did a little lesson this just
popped in my head um about like socks
with the kids and investing and then he
he gave them a little paper and they
created their own little investments and
stuff and kind of and they went through
the season of that
and so some they don't really teach that
in school and financial management um i
think is another one um
i thought you said socks at first but
you said stop stop
talks yeah stocks and financial
uh financial independence that type of
thing
is something that came to mind yes i
think that's an important one
yeah that's a huge focus for us for sure
my kids have really been geeking out on
stocks lately and checking their little
accounts every day and
always looking for coins and seeing what
they're worth and
um
i i just anything like literally
anything you can look at anyone and be
like what do they do i mention i'm
interested in that i'd like to know more
about that job you know there's
a billion jobs woodworking like we have
a friend um kyle who does like creates
these beautiful surfboards and i'm like
can you come over and teach my kid how
to do that you know and we did a little
um
a little build your own kind of car
thing and he came over and did that with
them and that was really fun yeah and so
i think um you can do woodworking you
can do
uh if there's a plumber and your your
kid wants to learn about plumbing you
know you can do plumbing like i think
life type skills are things that they
don't really teach in school cooking um
i don't know i can't think yeah like i
think of like geology i think about i
think about even learning about like
national parks and um things like like
building things like when them our kids
built uh the well the skate room the
skate ramp with quinn and just just
literally whatever they're interested in
which is super super cool so they have
those core subjects they're learning
about all those things like anatomy and
um you know biology and
english and writing but there's also so
many other things that like they really
wouldn't get at school and even
something like creative it makes me
think of the ted talk does school kill
creativity by sir ken robinson and how
he talks about this girl well you should
just watch it but basically like if
they're really creative and they're
really interested in doing something
like dancing and being able to have more
time to to do dancing that potentially
what if they want to make that their
career
and um like
realizing that there are creative
careers that we should emphasize and not
just try to put it aside a lot of times
school puts this like oh art's not as
important and
you know dance like that type of thing
just put it on the side but like people
actually make careers out of it and it's
something that entertains us as a as a
collective as a society um from people
who excel at that so yes absolutely yeah
okay so uh another question is what
creative ways are there to keep the
magic alive in learning
keep the magic alive and learning
i love that question i think there's so
many ways you just anything that pops
into your head like today
we want to go visit this museum or this
park or
visit this auntie or uncle who is has
this skill that they can teach us or
i don't know i just i don't think it
needs to be complicated i don't think
you need lots of art supplies or have to
have all these like special projects
that are really involved or anything
i think it's just like
i don't know looking around the world
and seeing everything as an opportunity
to learn
like is exciting you know
um
anything that brings you beyond like a
workbook and a desk is like
a successful trip totally yes and i
think um keeping the childhood
wonderment and imagination
alive is something that i'm i love and
it's important to me and so you know
reading fairy tales and myths and things
like that that
that maybe they don't really read in
school i'm not sure but
um i think that's really fun and magical
to me and and the kids love it too
because it gives them big imaginations
and allows their kind of creativity to
come out so yeah that actually makes me
think of jodi mockaby when her and her
book club that she does with her kids
she has she have five kids she has five
kids and they do book clubs like they
read the little women together and then
at the end like it was like a thing that
they did every week um reading the
chapters together and then at the end of
it they did this whole special um
uh
what it was it was like an experience
yeah a themed experience with tea and
all they're all dressed up
as a character in the book yes i know so
doing different things like that being
able to um engage in really special big
books where they're learning so much and
and making it a special event out of it
at the end just that's just an example
as well
another example was um
a few years back um we planned a kind of
fairy
hunt kind of thing through the forest
and that was really fun we put little
fairy fairy um doors on the different
trees and then a few of the trees you
picked up a little note that the fairy
left and it would say
something to do something kind or do
something kind of say this out loud and
and um and then at the end there was
this really fun little teepee made out
of wood kids got to play in and then
inside of there there was a special
little bag with different little um
treats and an activity for them to do so
that is just like i don't know so fun
and magical and brings nature and just
the wonder of childhood alive
i think a simple way too that we like to
kind of bring magic to subjects
especially if we are sitting down and
doing like work at a desk with a pen and
paper sort of thing is i have like music
on for everything so for learning about
vikings i'm like viking music on spotify
totally or you know like if when we did
um like a world study we kind of studied
each like area or continent for a month
and we get every single library book on
you know
africa or russia or whatever and then we
would cook a food and try to dress up or
do decorations or learn a game that they
play there
at the end of the month and have music
from from that place that we studied and
i just feel like there's so many easy
little ways to bring
magic to things that they don't have to
cost anything or be really elaborate
maybe
totally that makes me think of the
africa study that josefa did with our
kids and it was like a how long how many
months study was it
four weeks four weeks i feel like it was
more than that it could have been i
think it was a couple months study and
at the end doing this whole big party
with it and and also keeping all of
their projects in like a binder and like
josepha laminating them and to see look
at what they created where they're
drawing pictures of the flags and then
on the back they're writing a whole
paragraph about it being able to look
back at the party where they're all
showing each other their products or
projects and making certain foods from
the countries that they learned just
like all encompassing and making it
hands-on is really
really amazing which is something that
we enjoy as well as as adults and so i
just it gets me so excited just thinking
about school not having to be just
sitting at a desk and how you can learn
in so many different ways
okay my last question
what are some homeschooling authors or
resources that have inspired you that
people after listening to this can go
look into okay so jody maccubie for sure
love her
i love her notebooking manual
it shows you how to um
basically do beautiful illustrations and
then kind of write about it that's kind
of what we do in our schooling and i've
just fallen in love with that and she
has a lot of
great homeschooling resources on her
website also and then i love
the call of the wild and free i think
that is my favorite homeschool book
it's by ainsley arment
and
i think it's just amazing you have to
get it definitely read it because it
talks all about the different styles of
homeschooling talks it gives you
confidence as a parent to home school so
if you're like new to homeschooling or
want to homeschool or even if you are a
homeschooler i think it's a great um
resource to have
and those are my i would say my top two
i can't think
right now yeah that's a good one i would
have said call of the wild and free book
as well and that five hour school week
that i mentioned earlier awesome is
really encouraging for me it's how
children learn and how children fail
both books by john holt and then i also
really like the book dumbing us down by
john taylor gatto have you guys heard of
it he's an award-winning um teacher he
was a public school teacher for decades
and decades um he did like many speeches
for like oh being an award-winning
teacher from like the teacher of the
year from the entire country basically
like very famous teacher and he wrote a
book calling called dumbing astounding
explaining how after all his decades of
being a teacher he
learned so much that like this is not
how we should be teaching children like
this and it was it's really impactful
like to hear from him as a decades-long
teacher just seeing it in real life
being like
there's another way to do this to help
um like the title says not dumb us down
but rather uplift us and empower
children to
um just love learning and grow so much
from there so it's a short book it's a
really great book so those are those are
my favorites yeah cool this is such a
great conversation i'm so thankful to
have you guys here and that we had this
conversation um yeah i guess we should
end it but thank you so much for being
here and we'll probably hang out a
little bit after this because we're all
friends
all right
do you have anything to say
all right bye everybody
[Music]
you